okay last question and i think the
reason this question is in here
is because a lot of people that listen
to this podcast
they're trying to get better trying to
improve themselves they're trying to do
good and we all
and we got people of all ages this one
in particular says if giving a high
school graduation speech
what would you advise 18 year olds
navigating their first
their next steps would you tell an 18
year old
oh man um be humble or get humbled
damn i know dude we need to make a
t-shirt you are no i am
um
you know another way that this question
gets phrased and from what the story you
told tonight what would you tell
yourself if you could tell your own 18
year old self what would you tell
yourself
do something that you don't know if you
can accomplish
if i'm gonna climb a mountain yeah i
could go up to
you know mission san luis obispo you
know which is like a
2000 foot mountain and i'm pretty
confident i could climb that
you know um
mount whitney without some training
honestly
it'd be kind of challenging um
you know obviously k2 everest different
beasts could do it
do that do that
do that thing that you don't know if you
can do
stop being afraid of hard work
that's the thing that's gonna
really determine success or failure one
is your desire to actually do it and
then two
the commitment that it will take to
achieve it
stop being scared go and do it
that's what i'd say my
statement and i'd put it right on top of
that
i would say that not only do you want to
stop being scared and do that thing that
you don't
know if you can do or not but you know
what you got to do is you got to start
taking the steps
now because when you're 18 years old
your life seems like it's going to last
forever and i will tell you right now
it's not going to last forever
and those years go by
like a summer's day and the next thing
you know you look up
and you're 36 years old or you're 44
years old
and that time's gone you cannot get it
back you cannot
get time back
so those dreams that you have
those goals that you have don't put them
off another
second one not one second
get on them
and go out and make them happen starting
right now
drop the mics are suspended so you can't
drop them but
if you could that's what i would have
done i've just been like
i'm out